two dudes won the top spots on the
podium at the Illinois State Women's
cyclocross Championship over the weekend
which seems to have become the Illinois
state
cyclo championship if you ask me am I
right I'm right of course I'm right this
is very sad for the women who trained
because they were robbed of their prizes
by men who are by Nature bigger faster
and stronger than they are the Silver
Lining however is that this is great for
us at the daily wire since we just
released a new comedy movie lady Ballers
on this very topic the biggest moral
hesitation that we had making this movie
Jeremy talked about it this week last
week rather at the premiere is that the
filming involved watching Men dominate
women at sports including contact Sports
now of course the movie hired stunt
coordinators and stunt actors everything
was filmed in the gentlest possible way
but it's still tough to watch men
wrestle tackle throw basketballs at
women normal people don't ever want to
subject women to that sort of thing even
for a movie and yet that's the point
this is not just happening in comedy
movies it's only happening in one comedy
movie and only then because it's
happening all over the place in real
life where it is even harder to watch
I'm Michael nolles this is the Michael
nolles Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show if you've not
seen lady Ballers from the daily wire
you are missing out on the most
triggering comedy of the year I hate
that stupid catchphrase but I guess it's
true it has triggered a lot of people so
truth and marketing I suppose it is the
biggest launch in dailywire history you
can watch exclusively on dailywire plus
are you not a member well that's sad for
you luckily for you with code Coach Co a
you can become a part of the dailywire
plus team and save 50 bucks on new
annual
memberships Bill
Mah is is coming on over to our side
even the libs are coming on over to our
side mentioning that Donald Trump is
right about something going after Biden
a little bit and and specifically on one
issue that that I think is a huge winner
for republicans in 2024 we'll get to
that in one second first though I got to
go all the way across the world to
Dubai I got to go all the way across the
world to The Coop 28 un climate
conference we talked about it yesterday
that that's the conference for which all
of these Global liberal Elites just
hopped in their private jets even on
snow covered tarmacs to fly off emitting
20 times the air pollution that they
would have emitted had they flown on a
commercial aircraft and they they've
gone all the way to the Arabian
Peninsula to talk about how to stop the
sun monster from killing all of us in 5
seconds and how to talk about the
imminent end of humanity because people
drive around in cars that use gasoline
and so I was waiting for this to be an
absolutely insufferable liberal gabfest
and then I was so pleasantly
surprised when not just an attendee but
the president of the UN climate
conference Sultan Al Jabar of the United
Arab
Emirates took the occasion as an
opportunity to completely destroy the
climate alarmists with facts and logic
and fossil fuels you can Le by example
and like I said from the beginning I
accepted to come to this uh to this
meeting to to have a sober and a mature
uh conversation uh we do not I'm not in
any way signing up to any discussion
that is alarmist I am here factual and I
respect the science and there is no
science out there or no scenario out
there that says that the phase out of
fossil fuel is what's going to achieve
1.5 1.5 is my notar and a phase down and
a phase out of fil fuel in my view is
inevitable it is essential but we need
to be real serious and pragmatic about
it the science is very acute now we
don't have any time they say six or
seven years we' got to Peak by 2025
latest in fossil fuel fossil fuel and
your company is investing in a lot more
new fossil fuel and that's that's that's
going to hurt women so he you hear him
starting to interject here this is where
it really turns I love the opening goes
look this I'm here to have sober
discussion you crazy Western women I
invite you crazy Western liberal women
to come onto the screen we talk we talk
about we want to protect environment I
like environment but you tell me we're
not going to do the gas and the oil
anymore and you're all just absolutely
hysterical and crazy and these women
don't quite know what to do so so one of
them says well no actually the science
is very clear if we don't all stop
driving our automobiles by February
we're all going to to die and you'll
notice that the science has been very
very clear about the need to urgently
stop doing all the stuff that we do that
powers our economies within just a few
years it's always since the 1970s we've
heard this we only have a few years left
if we don't completely upend the economy
and the political order within a few
years we're all going to die immediately
and then it never happens and they
always keep pushing off that timeline
you heard this throughout the 80s I'm
sure if you went to school in the '90s
all you ever heard about was global
warming or the hole in the ozone layer
or acid rain or whatever whatever the
environmental uh scarecrow dour was and
then uh then we had Al Gore's big movie
in the 2000s that that was to tell us
that if we don't immediately upend our
political economy then oh in just a few
years Manhattan's going to be underwater
and Florida's going to be underwater and
then none of it happens and but because
they always have to push it off just a
few more years and sultan
aljabar leading this climate conference
he smacked it down for good uh ma'am
you've you've just accused me of
something that is not correct I'm sorry
I don't take it now I ask you to prove
to I read that company is is investing
in a lot more fossil fuel in the future
yes ma'am you're reading you're reading
your own media which is biased and
wronged I am telling you I am the man in
charge and it is wrong ma'am you need to
listen to me please very pleased to hear
it I'm very pleased to hear it it is
wrong you guys write a lie and you
believe it I'm sorry I do not accept
what I see I am not accepting this I'm
sorry I'm sorry I respect you and I do
not accept any false accusations I've
been very clear about my position this
is wrong and you're asking for a phase
out of fossil fuel please help me show
me a road map for a phas out of for of
view that will allow that will allow for
socio for sustainable socioeconomic
development unless you want to take the
world back into caves no show
me well well I I can't quite show you
actually you see because basically our
view here is that we got ours here in
the west and all of you poor brown
people need to give up electricity
because we got what we wanted and now
we're afraid of the sun monster and we
want to sacrifice your societies to
whichever demon we're we're deciding to
worship this week uh yes no lady no
thank you and my my favorite part of the
whole exchange my absolute favorite part
is just the firmness with which he says
no we're not going to do this we're not
going to allow you lunatic liberal
ideologues to push us around and tell us
that we have to impoverish all of our
people in our society just because of
your new religious cult no we're not
going to do
that and then my second favorite part is
is when she says well you don't
understand the reports have been very
clear he said those are reports from
your Western biased liberal media that
are not true show me the facts and then
furthermore this is the key because
everyone can come up with their own
paper funded by some Li liberal Think
Tank they can find all of their
statistics because there are lies damned
lies and statistics he asks a much more
difficult question that they can never
answer they can't pull up some study to
answer this one he said says show me the
road map as to how we are supposed to
totally eliminate fossil fuels how that
is going to reduce the global
temperature it's not you have no
scientific evidence that that's going to
happen but but more importantly show us
how we can do that without sending us
all back to caves they can't do it
there's no answer because because to the
liberal environmental extremists they
don't care if people flourish they don't
really like people that much the the
most extreme among them are
anti-natalist they say we need to stop
we need to stop having children to to
protect the
environment later on we'll talk about
this new fad of the dinks the dinkies no
double income no kids well there's
there's a variation of the dinks called
the ginks which is green inclined no
kids in fact I know people who have said
this who say I don't think I want have
kids because of how bad it would be for
the environment it's very
anti-human and you see this even in
their reforms of the economy
deformations of the economy where they
say yeah you're going to you're going to
drive less you're going to do less
you're going to consume less you're
going to you're going to you're going to
live Less in this world so that we can
offer it up to Mother Nature and Gaia
and the sun monster no no thank you when
we pray we should pray to the true God
which is why you ought to check out
hallow right now go to hall.com the
holidays are rapidly approaching but we
can find peace in the craziness of the
season with hallow the number one
Christian Prayer app in the world
immerse yourself in Christmas and Advent
prayers meditations and peaceful
Christmas music hallo also offers an
extensive library of Bible reading plans
accompanied by insightful Reflections
and Audi guided meditations whether you
are a seasoned Bible reader or just
starting your journey hallow provides a
platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before a great
place to start is with father Mike
schmitz's Bible in the year in which he
offers brief daily readings and
Reflections available on the Hallow app
the hall app also helps you connect with
a community of like-minded individuals
sharing experiences insights and
encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth this Christmas join
Hallow's Christmas prayer challenge
Advent with CS Lewis for the 25 days
leading up to Christmas you can focus on
the real reason for the season with
prayer meditation and Christmas music on
hallow Advent music as I prefer download
the app for free at hall.com
kwes for three months free that is
hall.com
moving on from the best climate
conference ever in the history of
climate activism but staying in the
Muslim
World Muslims in America seem to be
turning on Joe Biden on Saturday a bunch
of Muslim leaders from several States
and crucially several swing States
descended on Dearborn Michigan and they
did that to launch a national campaign
called the abandon Biden campaign and
they want to abandon Biden because they
view him as supporting Israel a lot of
people would say that Joe Biden is not
supporting Israel enough but these
Muslim leaders are saying he's
supporting Israel too much in the war
against Hamas so these are organizers
from Michigan Minnesota Arizona Arizona
is an important state just like Michigan
Wisconsin that's an important state
Florida's pretty solidly red but still
you know good to keep it Georgia
apparently that's a swing state Nevada
that's a swing state Pennsylvania o baby
that's a big swing State they are
calling for an abandoned Biden campaign
to which I
say this is great and Republicans better
not screw it
up now you might say well Michael I'm a
republican but I strongly support Israel
and so I don't want to be on the side of
these guys if if these guys are
attacking Joe Biden for not supporting
for rather for supporting Israel too
much to which I say
folks
politics actual practical politics is
not about the perfect expression of a
coherent philosophy actual practical
politics is about building coalitions
famously it's known as The Art of
inclusion bringing people together to do
things that are practical in the real
world and so I'm not saying that if
you're a huge Israel supporter you need
to abandon Israel far from it what I'm
saying is there are almost a quar
million Muslims in Michigan and Muslims
broke three quarters for the Democrats
in 2016 three out of four Muslims in
America voted for Hillary Clinton over
Donald Trump and now you're seeing a
movement a serious movement of Muslims
away from the Democratic party and I
don't think it's just Pie in the Sky I
think it's being caused by an actual
real world event that is rallying a lot
of Muslims all around the world and so
what Republicans might want to do is to
not screw it up when when your opponents
are are losing in this case when the
Democrats are losing support among an
important group don't get in their way
we don't need to come into the defense
of the Democrats here we don't
Republicans don't need to have any
particularly uh strong foreign policy
stance really on this kind of an
issue already you're seeing the Muslims
move away the Muslims started to move
away from the Democrats in 2020 more
more Muslims voted for Trump in in 2020
than they did in 2016 but this is a good
issue okay great let it happen it would
be very very good to let these Muslims
turn on Democrats and furthermore it's
not a completely
insane uh political Alliance at least
for
20124 yes it's true there have been some
conflicts between Christians and Muslims
for roughly 1,400 years now that's true
there have been certain invasions you
know things like the Battle of pitier
and lantto and Vienna there have been
the Crusades okay water under the bridge
folks because at the very least if I
were a Muslim I would look around and I
would say okay I don't what whatever you
think about the Israel Palestine
conflict I would further look around and
say these Democrats are completely
Godless they the Republicans tend to
worship a different God than we the
Muslims do but at least they acknowledge
that God
exists the Democrats want to completely
destroy the family Republicans might
have a slightly different version of
marriage and family than we do but at
least they at least they understand the
basic realities of marriage and family
okay there is a a natural attractiveness
if you are a Muslim to conservative
Republicans over
insane degenerate Democrats okay and so
while there might be differences the the
key for the Republicans here is don't
screw it up just try your best not to
alienate the Muslim voters in the swing
States they've come out and said they
don't want want to support Trump but if
enough of them can just not vote for
Biden that could be enough to swing the
election which would be a great thing
speaking of
trump there's a major warning out there
from a
self-styled Statesman no one else really
Styles her a Statesman but but she does
a States woman a States lady that would
be of course Liz Cheney trotted out once
again to do the only thing that she
exists for in politics and that is to
criticize her quote unquote fellow
Republican
because Liz Cheney pretends to be a
republican for that very purpose to play
The Court Jester in the Kingdom of
liberalism Liz Cheney is
warning that Donald Trump if he is
reelected might refuse to leave office
do you believe that Donald Trump were
elected next year that he would try to
stay in office Beyond a second term that
he would never leave office there's no
question you think he would try to stay
in power forever absolutely I mean he's
already done it once and in fact if you
look at what he did in the runup to
January 6th in terms of his pressure on
the vice president not to count
legitimate electoral votes his pressure
on the Department of Justice on state
officials and then refusing to send help
when the capital was under attack um
he's already attempted to seize power
and he was stopped um thankfully and and
for the good of the nation and the
Republic uh but but he said he will do
it again he's expressed No Remorse for
what he
did first of all this is a new criticism
I've never heard this one she says he
refused to send help when the capital
was under assault send help the capital
is outside of his jurisdiction that's
why there's something called the capital
police the capital police who were oddly
enough uh not called up to a full
security presence before January 6 the
worst day in the history of the Republic
that was kind of weird the Capitol
Police who stood down and let the the uh
January 6th there come in in some cases
they escorted them through the Capitol
building that was kind of weird of
course if Donald Trump had sent anyone
from the executive branch to assist they
that we would be told that that was
another part of the attempted coup
Donald Trump sending his secret police
to the sacred Halls of democracy in the
Congress attempting to take over a
branch of government so that's a that's
a new one I hadn't heard that one before
pretty ridiculous but the whole claim is
ridiculous because we know that Donald
Trump will not refuse to give up power
and the reason we know that is he
already did
it this is this is one of the strongest
aspects I think of the Trump candidacy
is when when people make these insane
hysterical alarmist claims we can point
back to history and see what actually
happened one of the strongest Parts
about Trump's candidacy is when it comes
to the fearmongers on the left we can
say well fool me once shame on you fool
me twice to quote George W the point is
you're not going to fool me
again Donald Trump if he's elected he's
going to start World War III oh well he
got elected and he didn't he was
actually the best foreign policy
president in our lifetime well Donald
Trump if he gets elected he's actually
going to be a secret liberal that's you
sometimes hear this from people on the
right uh no actually he was the most
conservative president in our lifetime
okay that's good Donald Trump gets
elected he's going to promote abortion
no actually he got roie Wade overruled
Donald Trump if he gets elected he's
going
to he's going to promote anti-Semitism
that was another one he's Hitler he's
going to promote anti-Semitism actually
they named a town after him in Israel so
I'm pretty sure he's not going to do
that well Donald Trump if he gets
elected he's not going to give up power
well actually last time you rigged the
election against him and he still gave
up power so nah I don't think
so this is also why I don't really sweat
it when Donald Trump says something
eccentric or that we might disagree with
you know on on whatever issue on
abortion or on whatever on LGBT issues
on the sexual Revolution because as I
look at him and I say huh okay well that
rhetoric is a little confusing but uh
actions speak louder than words and
we've already seen the show we know what
we're getting we know what show we're
going to see if we vote for Donald Trump
again and if Liz cheny ever had any
credibility I don't think she ever had
much uh that would be gone now we can
see through it just like you can see
through your windows when you want new
windows you got to check out Renewal by
Anderson right now text nolles to 200
300 for most homeowners window
replacement is not something that they
want to do but something they have to do
have you put off replacing the windows
in your home because it's too expensive
well then I've got great news you can
now get a free inhome window
consultation and a free quote from
Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible supported
by the best people in the industry right
now Renewal by Anderson is offering a
free inhome or virtual consult
consultation UND durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for $0
down zero payments and zero interest for
one year text nolles KW Lees to 200 300
for your free consultation save 375
bucks off every window and 750 bucks off
every door these savings will not last
long so be sure to check it out text
nolles kW to 200 300 that's nolles to
200 300 I got an email from a carpenter
one time he said every time I go to a
house with with Renewal by Anderson I
can hell immediately it's such higher
quality plus I have a cousin who works
for them and can't say enough good
things about them texting privacy policy
and terms of conditions posted at text
plan. us texting enrolls for recurring
automated TT marketing messages message
and data rates may apply reply stop to
opt out go to window appointment now.com
for full offer details folks have I
mentioned that that the daily wire made
a full featurelength comedy lady Ballers
I think I might have mentioned it once
or twice it's a hilarious movie that
calls out we already know that that men
are stronger than women physically at
least well it's official lady Ballers is
now the most popular streaming movie on
Rotten Tomatoes it's got an incredible
audience score of 97% it's got thousands
of reviews lady Ballers is also one of
the most popular movies on IMDb it is
streaming now exclusively on daily War
plus if you still do not have a dawi
plus membership get 50 bucks off
dailywire plus annual subscriptions with
code coach at dailywire.com subscribe
watch our very first comedy lady Ballers
we are just getting started with comedy
at Daily wire our new animated comedy
series from Adam Corolla Mr burum is
coming early 2024 you will be the first
first to see it with your dailywire plus
annual membership not in the mood for
comedy that's fine daily wire's highly
anticipated series The Pen Dragon cycle
inspired by the renowned works of
acclaimed Christian novelist Steven R
lawhead is also coming in 2024 most
importantly it's your chance to join us
in the battle for our culture and build
the future that we want to see get 50
bucks off your dailywire plus annual
subscription with code coach at
dailywire.com
subscribe speaking of big
Libs a couple just went V viral for
bragging about the dink lifestyle we're
dinks we're going to get asked daily
when we plan on having kids we're dinks
of course we're going to go out to eat
every night after work we're dinks we
don't have to ask our family for
financial help or to watch our kid when
we want to go out we're dinks we're
going to go to Costco and buy all the
snacks in bulk that we want we're dinks
we have disposable income to spend on
whatever we would like and don't have to
spend on a kid we're dings I'm going to
go to Every football game and play 18
holes whenever I want we're dinks we're
going to get asked to every single
family event what we're doing with our
life I'm depressed because I just
watched this video I'm very sad about
the state of our culture because I just
watched that video I'm frankly not
betting on much of a future for Western
Civilization because I just watched that
video I'm I'm Michael I'm
Michael this new
trend put the dinks aside for a second
this new trend of the I'm blah blah blah
and blah blah blah blah blah blah that
I've seen go around the Internet it's
absolutely unbearable and it's
especially unbearable when you're
talking about something like the dinks
because what we're looking at here is
not merely a couple suffering from
infertility who knows maybe they did
suffer for maybe they did really want
kids and now they're just coping and
they're putting on a strong face about
it and trying to promote something that
they don't actually desire that could be
the case many people do
that but what they're at least doing on
the surface is they are saying it is
better to intentionally abstain from
having
kids if you are a married couple and
that is obviously not true that's not
what marriage is for marriage is for
having kids not everyone gets to some
people are infertile it's a a terribly
difficult experience to go
through but that's what it's for you you
can have a good life without children
if you're a married couple and you're
infertile you can be God Parents you can
be very involved in the lives of your
nieces and nephews you can be very
involved in the life of your community
say your church or other Civic
associations you
can if you are single and you're not
going to have kids you can join a
religious order you can consecrate your
singlehood to to God you can do things
for other people with the extra time and
money that you have for not having
kids all of that is
true the one thing that will certainly
not make you happy if you are a married
couple without kids is doing what these
people are
suggesting we're dinks we get to buy a
lot of snacks at Costco I have multiple
children I I can buy the snacks that I
want at Costco Costco is has really
great prices
and lots of snacks frankly you don't
even have to pay for the snacks at
Costco CU they have so many free
samples that your children are not
preventing you from buying
Doritos we're dinks we get to go to
dinner every night that's I don't get to
go out to dinner every night that's
true dinner every night at restaurants
gets very boring sometimes it's nice to
sit at home with your family and have
dinner we're dinks I get to go to
football games all the time football
games are you can watch them on TV first
of all I'm not a huge football guy but
you can watch them on TV it's okay and
you can take your kids to football games
and that's more enjoyable than just
going
alone we're dinks so I get to go golfing
whenever I want yeah golf is guys don't
I think it was Shaw who said that hell
is the place where you have nothing to
do but amuse
yourself there are plenty of things I
like to do on my own I like to smoke
cigars I like to read books I like to
strum my UK L I even like to paint I'm
not a good painter but I like painting I
like to go on walks I like to do all
sorts of fun
things it gets old it gets old I I know
people who have intentionally not had
children I'm not kidding because they
really like going to
brunch they really like going out to
brunch and they really like traveling
say especially Millennials they love
that unch has diminishing marginal
Returns on happiness even traveling has
diminishing I love traveling I've
traveled extensively it even that has
diminishing marginal returns it is true
that when you have kids you will have
less disposable income you will have
less time you'll sleep a lot less you'll
be stressed more in some
cases the Sublimity of
children is is simply Indescribable I
would not be able to do it justice here
I remember I I give you at least one one
little sketch to give you a sense of
it my first book with words I guess my
only book with words for now and my
first baby were both due on the same day
couple of years
ago and I of course pushed it to the
deadline as did my baby and so we're
sitting in the delivery room and it's my
poor wife just screaming you know
preparing to give birth and me fixing
the footnotes on my manuscript before I
sent it off to the publisher and I had
really
put my heart and soul into this book
spent a long time writing it put put my
back into it and I finally send it off
my wife had even said she goes you know
I'm giving birth to my baby you're
giving birth to your baby and I finally
sent off the manuscript of something
I've been working on for 18 months
longer than my wife had been working on
our baby and then my wife delivered our
son and I realized in that moment that
my book didn't matter at all it became a
number one National bestseller
speechless controlling words controlling
mons you can order it now if you like oh
thank you very much much but doesn't
matter at
all similar to what St Thomas aquinus
said after he had a a mystical Vision at
the end of his life and St Thomas
aquinus the one of the most important
intellectuals ever to walk the
earth wrote the Suma theologia among
many other works was said to be able to
write multiple books at a
time and he he had a mystical vision and
he said oh all that I have written is so
much straw doesn't none of that matter
matters brunch doesn't matter football
doesn't matter your snacks at Costco
they don't matter at all when it when it
comes to a much deeper purpose like the
deepest like the purpose of your
marriage just absolute Peak decadence
and Hedonism have I been harsh enough I
think I have I think maybe I have there
are things that this couple can do if
they can't have kids golfing and eating
snacks is not among the things that will
make them happy now speaking of
decadence and
Hedonism you know I hate to say I Told
You So in this case I really hate to say
I told you so I've been going on for
years now really ever since the rise of
AI and we've been hearing all these
horror stories about how AI is going to
put us all out of work I said that's not
the big problem with AI That's not what
it's going to be used for and we've been
told AI it's going to
threaten weaponry and military
installations around the world I said
that's not the big fear that's not what
AI is going to be used for I said the
big thing that you got to worry about
with AI is that pretty much the only
thing it's going to be used for is porn
and degrading people and uh stopping us
from procreating and ending human
civilization that way that's said that's
the big forget about the military uses
and the economic disruption the main
issue is it's all going to be used for
porn and it turns out a new survey says
I was totally right this is from The
Daily Mail the Unstoppable rise of deep
fake porn so here are the highlights
from this study
porn makes up 98% of all deep fakes
according to a report by security firm
home security Heroes not surprised
whatsoever I'm surprised the number is
so low saying oh well with deep fakes
we're not going to be able to tell what
the politicians are saying anymore don't
worry about that no one's going to spend
any time doing deep fakes of politicians
because they're all going to be spending
their time making porn out of deep fakes
and what did I say about the Deep fake
porn I said the real fear here is not
that it's going to create scandal with
celebrities so the the real fear here is
that with this kind of Technology it's
going to be a kid in his math class
doing it to his
classmate and she's going to be
profoundly violated and these videos are
going to go all around the internet
she's not even going to know what
happened which turns out is exactly what
happened in October male students in a
New Jersey high school were caught
sharing AI generated nudes featuring the
faces of their female classmates some as
young as 14 years old and then here's
what one of the victims said we we're
aware that there are creepy guys out
there but you would never think one of
your classmates would violate you like
this and I'd put a pause there I did
think that a classmate would violate
them like this these girls did not
they're young they're naive they're
Innocent but there are many adults who
would who would not foresee this
happening
because all of this has been allowed to
proliferate because of major willing
ignorance major confusion about
fundamental aspects of human nature they
keep going on disturbingly most of these
AI tools do not work on images of Men In
fact when the news website Vice tested
one app by uploading a picture of a man
his underwear was replaced with female
genitalia gee you don't say what these
guys they're they're legitimately
shocked by this they're legitimately
shocked
that everyone who uses this technology
is a man and there further they
legitimately shocked that very few of
those men are
homosexual they're sh because why
because we've been told for our lives if
you're a millennial for your whole life
you've been told oh men and women are
exactly the same and they relate to sex
in exactly the same way and the other
thing you've been told is that like 50%
of people are gay which just isn't true
it's even with how how much those sorts
of desires and behaviors are promoted in
our culture it's still a very small
number of people so the vast majority of
guys using of people using this are men
who are attracted to
women who when they are unconstrained by
morality and the law have very very
creepy desires that they give way to
finally they say currently there is no
federal mandate that banss the creation
or distribution of deeg pornography yeah
gee you don't say you don't say this
problem we're told it's the Unstoppable
rise of deep fake porn I don't think
it's Unstoppable I don't think it's un
we were told that about nuclear weapons
the proliferation of nuclear weapons is
totally Unstoppable everyone's going to
have it in 5 minutes it didn't happen we
were able to extraordinarily slow down
the spread of nuclear
weapons it it's still spreading a little
bit but but very very slowly the same
could be true of this kind of
Technology the reason that it's taking
off right now is because of four related
problems confusion about the
Sexes we refuse to acknowledge that men
and women relate to sex differently
and Men generally speaking men desire
and women are desired generally speaking
men chase the girls and the girls are
chased by the men generally
speaking men are willing have a much
higher sex drive and are willing to do
lots of weird stuff and the women have
to protect against that through
something called modesty which we used
to hold up as a virtue in our society
and now we mock as a relic of of an
Antiquated and silly age but turns out
the gods of the copy book headings are
reasserting themselves that's the first
confusion second one is confusion about
Freedom we think that freedom is just
the ability to choose and do whatever
you want whenever you want to do it
that's not Freedom it's not how our F
fathers thought about Freedom it's not
how any serious thinker in our whole
civilization has thought about freedom
freedom is not just neutrally choosing
between opposites if if that were the
case God would not be free if that were
the case then every time you build a
habit or a virtue You' you'd become less
free freedom is perfect willing the
ability to to do that which you really
want to do which involves discipline
disciplining your base appetites to your
rational will and and perfect willing is
dependent upon intellect it's about
knowing things if you're extremely
ignorant you're going to be less free
you're going to be a slave and now we
have a culture that has absolutely no
discipline and absolutely no knowledge
so we're we we call ourselves free
because we get to look at weird porn all
the time but we're actually enslaved to
Vices such as pornography among many
others in our culture that's the second
one third one is confusion about the law
we even on the right have bought into a
crazy kind of extreme libertarianism
it's really
libertinism which says that law is
always bad and government is always bad
that's not true fending fathers didn't
think that they weren't
anarchists law is good law is a teacher
when you incentivize certain behaviors
you get more of those behaviors when you
disincentivize certain behaviors by
punishing them with the law then you get
less of those behaviors people have
tried to pass la against this stuff for
years now and liberal radical judges
have shot it down like the
communications decency Act and the child
online protection act had those laws
been passed in the 90s you wouldn't see
half of these problems right now and
then the biggest issue the biggest
driver of this kind of problem is
something that Americans are
particularly susceptible to and that is
a denial of original
sin that is a denial of the fact go out
on the street ask people do you believe
in original sin I bet I bet many if not
most people in America would tell you no
I don't believe in that what's that mean
some little babies
born with with some sins no man it's
society that puts sin put sin and
imperfection on people that but we're
all we're all born with all the stuff we
need to be perfect I mean this is the
progressive Vision this is frankly the
enlightenment vision of
man what what it really comes down to is
can you save yourself can you be perfect
totally perfect and without sin of your
own effort by your own Works do you
believe
that many people say yes many people say
oh yeah I don't need a God I don't need
a savior I don't need I can do it we
just we don't need imagine there's no
religion man it's easy if you try y
right that that's that
is not only part of the left-wing
culture today that's actually
unfortunately a theme that recurs in the
American tradition and it's not
true I I know there are some creepy men
out there but would my classmates do
this yeah yes every single one of your
male classmates would do this kind of
creepy stuff if they were not
constrained by cultural norms religious
and moral prescriptions and the law and
even then some of them are going to do
it but I promise you without any of
those restraints every single one of
your male classmates is going to do this
so don't say it's Unstoppable don't say
you weren't warned don't say well this
is just something we got to deal with
this is creepy this is wrong this is a
deep violation of women and young girls
and we can stop
it if we just throw away our false
ideology if we fix our confusion on
really basic issues and act normal act
like a normal society now speaking of
young people talk about really really
young people when you want to help the
youngest and most innocent helpless
Among Us you got to check out pre-born
right now go to pre-born docomo finally
the perfect gift for someone who has
everything a gift that will reach
eternity pre-born gives this gift 200
times every day rescuing babies whose
lives are in Peril these babies lives
are precious and beautiful their heart
begins to form a conception and at just
3 weeks it's already beating at five
weeks a baby's heartbeat can be heard on
ultrasound by 6 weeks eyes are forming
by 10 weeks a baby can suck his or her
thumb pre-born needs our help to save
these precious souls for just $28 you
can sponsor an ultrasound and introduce
a mother to her baby which doubles that
baby's chance at life and right now
through a matching Grant your gift saves
twice as many babies please give the
gift of Life they fund raise separately
for their administrative cost so every
dollar you give goes right toward saving
babies this is where you've got to give
especially as the end of the year
approaches have your donation matched
today by dialing pound 250 saying say
the keyword baby that is pound 250
keyword baby or donate securely at
pre-born docomo canw that is pre-born
dcoms my favorite comment yesterday is
from grunt
9950 comment is yes the annual
choreography of private jets flying all
over the world carrying one person at a
time to bother us about climate change
there it is it's part of the ritual the
climate religion has all sorts of Rights
and rituals it's got all sorts of
sacramentals you know the reusable water
bottle the paper straws these are
sacramentals in the cult of the of the
environment and one of the annual
rituals it's a big Festival is when all
the private jets take off to Ferry John
KY and all the rest of them to the other
side of the world to talk about how
awful it is that we drive our cars now
speaking of
sin is a clip is from a few days ago but
I I want to get to it of Faith leaders
in Iowa praying over Donald Trump Lord I
pray for protection over him I pray for
protection over his family and Lord that
all the weapons formed against him will
not Pros Lord they will come to nothing
and The Traps that have been laid
against them the people that laid the
traps they will be caught in their own
traps yes so father we thank you now
Lord for a great favor and I pray Lord
that we will that presid Trump will
trust in
you his understanding acknowledge you in
all his ways Lord and I trust you that
you will direct his paths and Lord there
is a great Victory not only this nation
but for the world because of the calling
and the that you placed on this
man we say this in agreement uh right
now and Lord we thank you that it should
be done by Our Father in
heaven so the Liberals are sending this
clip all around and and they're
pretending that it's really weird some
are suggesting that conservatives
worship Donald Trump because they don't
they just don't understand how religion
Works certainly not the Christian
religion so they don't realize that what
you're seeing there is not only not the
worship of Donald Trump it's the
opposite of the worship of Donald Trump
it is a recognition by faith leaders in
Iowa that this is a fallen broken man
who is susceptible to all sorts of sin
and vice and so they are praying to God
to protect him from spiritual warfare
the reality of which the Liberals also
deny because they deny that there's good
and bad and the personality of good and
bad and they deny the they angels and
demons and spiritual warfare they deny
all of these
things they adopt a mostly materialist
Outlook even if they sometimes
contradict that with the the natural uh
intuitions of metaphysical reality you
see this especially in the transgender
ideology where they say your body has
nothing to do with who you are but
that's a that's a little crack in the
otherwise materialist facade of their
their
worldview it's good to pray for your
leaders even if you don't like Trump
even if you hate Trump even if you're a
big Democrat and you love Joe
Biden it's good to pray for your leaders
even if you're a big Republican you and
you hate Joe
Biden we want we want to pray for our
leaders we want at least for their
conversion we want the leaders to do
well in as much as what they do is
conducive to our flourishing we want to
have a grand strategic vision for our
country we want to have patriotism which
is a good thing and and an extension of
filial
piety we there used to be a universal
acceptance of this that's broken down in
the last probably 20 years a little more
than 20 years especially on the
right it's good you should you should be
praying for your for your national
leaders at church we we used to do this
we don't we don't have that anymore and
as that breaks down then the political
problems are going to be a lot deeper
than just some guy or other in office uh
before we close
today I'm I'll give you a little tease
we'll get more to the
story we'll get more to the story
tomorrow but it's sad if you're driving
pullover if you're standing up please
sit down a a presidential candidate is
out that would be Doug
beram the dream the dream is over the
bergam mum has come to a grinding
halt it's a reminder
that a lot of candidates are
out Pence
Scott
bergham Larry
Elder a lot of candidates are out
they've all been taken out I think by
you know who by Chris Christie who
remains in the race the Chris
assant continues he will be at the
debate nobody
expects the Chris
son we'll get more to it later the rest
of the show continues now you do not
want to miss it become a member use code
NS can has a check out for 2 months free
on annual
[Music]
plans